YUFENG GUO: Previously
on AI Adventures,
we looked at Colab
as a great way
to get started in the data
science and machine learning
world.
But there are some
models out there
that need to run for a
long time or you want
to get more memory or GPUs.
How can we hook up Colab
with some more compute power?
Stay tuned to find out.
Welcome to AI Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode,
we're going to use Google
Cloud Platform's deep learning
VMs to power your
Colab environment.
A few episodes ago,
we looked at how
to create deep learning VMs with
your choice of machine learning
frameworks.
Today, we'll use that VM
and connect Colab to it
so we can utilize the
resources on that machine.
To start out, we'll of
course need to make our VM.
And let's make it a big one.
Head on over to the
Cloud Marketplace,
and we'll find the deep
learning VM and select it.
OK.
Now, to select our parameters.
Let's give it a name.
Say colab-box.
And for good
measure, we'll do 8--
no, 16 CPUs, and how
about 60 gigs of memory?
And now for the GPUs.
Let's choose the V100s.
And we'll have two of them.
Yeah.
Now we're really cooking.
While we're waiting
for that to spin up,
let's talk a bit about
how we're going to get
Colab to talk to your VM.
There are two tricks
that we're going to use,
which together make this
connection possible.
The first is that
Colab can actually
connect to any local runtime.
So if you have a local Jupyter
Notebook Server running,
say on your laptop,
you can use Colab
if you want as your front
end to that server rather
than the usual Jupyter
Notebook front end.
And you can access that in the
upper right-hand menu of Colab.
The second trick that
we'll take advantage
of is that you can do port
forwarding on the deep learning
VM we just created so
that it can be accessed
from your local machine.
You can do that with
the command shown here.
And be sure to run it from
your actual local terminal
on your machine and not
in, say, Cloud Shell.
In this particular situation,
since we wish to port forward
to our local machine
actually, running the command
in Cloud Shell doesn't
really achieve our goals.
We don't need a port
forward to the Cloud Shell.
Typically, having this
port forwarding setup
would just mean that we
can access the Jupyter
Server from a local front end.
But if we open up
Colab and tell it
to connect to our local
runtime, that local runtime
will, in fact, be the
port forwarded one
from deep learning VM.
And thus, the two
become connected.
So now when you hook
the two together,
we can see that, yes
indeed, we have our two V100
GPUs running and accessible
from our Colab front end.
So now you understand how
Colab and deep learning VMs
can work together and how to
get your setup just so, based
on how your needs are
changing, both in terms of what
the front end
looks like and what
back-end system is driving it.
For example, you can develop
against a local back end
initially, and then when
you want to get more power,
move up to the deep learning VM.
So how do you set up your
data science environment,
and how do you allow
it to change, flex,
and grow as needed?
Let me know in the
comments below.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
And if you enjoyed
it, be sure to like
and subscribe to get all
the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, head over to
the Deep Learning VMs
and try connecting it
with your Colab Notebook.
[MUSIC PLAYING]